[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis einen schönen guten
abend wünsche ich ihnen und herzlich
willkommen was beim sport passiert ist
erfahren sie von norbert lehmann gründer
und die mögliche ampel koalition will
sich viel vornehmen aber wie soll das
bezahlt werden darüber herrscht
uneinigkeit eines unserer themen heute
debatte um klimaschädliche subventionen
grüne und fdp streiten ob die
pendlerpauschale abgeschafft werden soll
deutschland in der vierten corona welle
es gibt mehr neuinfektionen als vor
einem jahr und weniger pflegekräfte auf
intensivstationen und
aufbruch ins all der saarländer matthias
maurer steht kurz vor seinem flug zur
internationalen raumstation iss
geräuschlos sollen die verhandlungen zur
ampelkoalition laufen aber zwist dringt
dann doch nach draußen denn eine große
offene frage ist immer noch welche klima
schädlichen subventionen sollen
abgeschafft werden um das geld für
geplante vorhaben zu kriegen die fdp
hält bereits an der pendlerpauschale
fest david gebert steuerliche förderung
für berufspendler für dieselfahrer oder
dienstwagen inhaber welche subventionen
wollen die ampel parteien ausknipsen für
welche gibt es weiterhin einen
freifahrtsschein es knirscht die grünen
fordern nun klimaschädliche subventionen
im verkehrsbereich massiv abzubauen es
macht keinen sinn auf der einen seite
klimaschutz mit milliarden steuergelder
zu fördern und auf der anderen seite die
klima verschmutzung die befeuerung der
klimakrise dann auch mit milliarden
steuergelder zu fördern dass es wieder
nicht fahrrad fahren und kräftig in die
pedale treten und gleichzeitig die
bremse ziehen ist auch klar dann falle
ich vom rad beispielsweise die
pendlerpauschale die steuerliche
absetzbarkeit von fahrtkosten für den
weg zur arbeit gilt kritikern als
klimaschädlich weil sie auch die nutzung
des autos begünstigt doch hier stellt
fdp chef lindner heute ein stoppschild
auf
subventionsabbau darf aber nicht zu
einer steuererhöhung für die arbeitende
mitte werden wie es bei der
pendlerpauschale der fall wäre gerade
auf dem land ist das auto für pendler
noch existenziell und so wirft die
pauschale neben der klima auch die
soziale frage auf die pendlerpauschale
generiert verkehr und ist damit
klimaschädlich wenn sie sich anschauen
wer von der pendlerpauschale profitiert
dann sind das die oberen
einkommensschichten wir würden das
instrument so umbauen dass die unteren
einkommensschichten davon wirklich
profitieren können und gleichzeitig
würden wir so einen beitrag zum
klimaschutz leisten sozial ausgewogen
marktliberal und klimafreundlich will
die mögliche ampelkoalition sein im
bereich verkehr und subventionen muss
sie dieses kunststück erstmals auf die
straße bringen
und während die spd noch mit grünen und
fdp verhandelt muss sie sich schon mal
gedanken über eine neue parteispitze
machen denn überraschend hat spd co chef
norbert walter borjans heute seinen
rückzug angekündigt warum und wer ihm
nachfolgen könnte zeigt ihnen andreas
künast
als im politischen berlin früh an diesem
morgen spd-chef nummer 17 auf einer
bühne an der spree steht eine nur wenige
dass ab diesem abend nummer 18 gesucht
wird norbert walter borjans der beim
aktionstag der ig metall spricht über
ein parteitag im dezember nicht noch
einmal antreten einer zeitung hat er
diktiert die mission die spd zurück auf
kurs zu bringen sei erfüllt
mit seiner entscheidung bringt walter
borjans die welt der spd noch einmal zum
schwingen bleibt die doppelspitze bleibt
saskia esken und hält die einigkeit
zwischen partei rechts und partei links
bin ganz sicher die ganz
unterschiedlichen interessen werden in
einem großen parteivorstand auch zu wort
und letztlich eben auch zu einer
kandidatur kommen als möglicher kandidat
genannt wird generalsekretär klingbeil
nachdem die große frage will ein kanzler
scholz nicht selbst parteichef seien
beantwortet ist mit nein klar ist aber
auch dass ich mich auf das konzentrieren
wofür ich von den bürgerinnen bürgern
auftrag bekommen habe nämlich eine
regierung zu bilden und der nächste
kanzler der bundesrepublik deutschland
zu werden die spd ist dankbar dass ihr
chef nummer 17 nicht im streit und nicht
knall auf fall geht und dass noch sechs
wochen zeit sind nummer 18 zu finden
der winter naht es wird kälter und
dadurch stecken sich auch immer mehr
menschen mit infektionskrankheiten an
viele intensivstationen sind bereits
ziemlich voll und dazu kommen jetzt auch
wieder vermehrt cupid 19 patientinnen
und patienten das problem die anzahl
intensivbetten ist deutlich geschrumpft
im vergleich zum vorjahr nämlich um fast
17 prozent
denn es gibt nicht genug pflegepersonal
constanze kainz und muss neues
im klinikum ludwigsburg sind die
intensivbetten fast alle belegt und die
vierte welle baut sich gerade erst auf
für jaqueline finke bedeutet das wieder
arbeiten bis zur belastbarkeitsgrenze
und darüber hinaus einfach müde ich bin
ausgelaugt und ich frag mich jeden tag
kann ich eigentlich noch bis zur arbeit
kommen oft dachte sie daran aufzuhören
tausende andere pflegekräfte haben
mittlerweile gekündigt deshalb muss rund
jedes dritte intensiv bett in
deutschland leer bleiben dabei ist die
lage auf den stationen bereits
angespannt auch wegen anderer
infektionskrankheiten waren
intensivmediziner in jetzt kobe dazu
kommt und das täglich steigt dann kommen
wir relativ schnell an die
kapazitätsgrenzen in der regulären
versorgung die folge operationen müssten
verschoben werden krankenhäuser wieder
in den notfall betrieb doch anders als
im vorjahr mit noch weniger personal die
belastung riesig
und auf intensivstationen kritisch
kranken patient betreute das vielleicht
auch wieder beleben muss sind
verkehrsunfall dann sind das acht
stunden wo man 100 leistet dann
hoffentlich ein positives ergebnis hat
der patient überlebt hat mit kurbelt es
ist aber einfach so dass man hier vier
bis sechs wochen 100 prozent leisten und
heben muss und dann mit einem sehr
ungewissen ausgang so wirkt corona wie
ein brennglas auf ein strukturelles
personalproblem in den krankenhäusern
jaqueline finke land einen neuen
kollegen an und hofft dass wenigstens er
bleiben wird
um die krankenhäuser zu entlasten und
die pandemie einzudämmen ruft der
bundesgesundheitsminister zu
auffrischungsimpfungen auf und regt an
dass alle menschen ab 60 jahren dazu
eingeladen werden warum gehen die korona
zahlen zurzeit wieder hoch pablo sie
lala hier ist dieser frage nachgegangen
die abstände im clubs und restaurants
werden wieder kleiner an vielen orten
fällt die masken pflicht deutschland
macht sich locker vielleicht zu locker
wir haben immer weniger maßnahmen die
impfung ist weit fortgeschritten und
auch bei den geimpften für das eben dazu
dass nicht mehr so strikt natürlich
bestimmte maßnahmen eingehalten werden
inzwischen sind 66,6 prozent der
deutschen vollständig geimpft doch
experten rechnen damit dass die wirkung
nach drei monaten deutlich nachlassen
könnte man kann das nicht
pauschalisieren die menschen reagieren
ja durchaus auch unterschiedlich auf
diese impfung und entwickeln einen
unterschiedlich starken in schutz aber
dieses phänomen tritt ihm gehäuft bei
den besonders alten menschen haben
professor torsten lehr von der
universität des saarlandes ist corona
modellierer er errechnet anhand von
modellen wie sich die kurve zahlen
entwickeln wir gehen aber davon aus dass
in den nächsten wochen die inzidenz
erstmal noch weiter steigen wird auch
mit der ähnlichen geschwindigkeit wie
wir das momentan sehen wir haben aber
oft gesehen dass bei höheren instanzen
die bevölkerung sich dann auch
reflexartig zurücknimmt und kontakte
meidet und mobilität einschränkt und
dadurch auch die
letztendlich die instanzen sinken werden
die situation deutlich verbessern würde
eine dritte impfung die so genannte
booster impfung und klinische daten
zeigen uns auch wirklich dass die
übertragungs wahrscheinlichkeit des
virus zurück geht das heißt also
wirklich das gebürstete wirklich kaum
noch zum infektionsgeschehen beitragen
eine booster impfung sei auf jeden fall
sinnvoll für menschen aller
altersgruppen die
pandemie auch großes thema in unserem
aktuellen politbarometer und dazu ist
matthias fornoff bei uns im studio guten
abend matthias wie blicken denn die
befragten auf die korona situation naja
kroner bereitet tatsächlich immer mehr
menschen wieder sorge die eigene
gesundheit halten jetzt 47 prozent für
gefährdet anfang oktober befürchteten
dass nur 31 prozent vor diesem
hintergrund wird auch eine impfpflicht
für bestimmte bereiche zum thema dass
sich das personal im gesundheitswesen
impfen lassen muss finden 72 prozent der
befragten eine impfpflicht für lehrer
und kita personal halten 64 prozent für
richtig und sollte das öffentliche leben
stärker eingeschränkt werden wenn die
zahlen weiter steigen
das sollte generell für alle passieren
sagen 32 prozent einschränkungen nur für
nicht geimpfte fordern 43 prozent das
auch zeit mitgebracht zu den parteien
wer gewinnt in der zustimmung der
verliert nur in der politischen
landschaft ist eher wenig bewegung wenn
am sonntag bundestagswahl wäre bliebe
die spd stärkste partei
27 prozent minus eins im vergleich zur
umfrage vor zwei wochen um rund 20
prozent +1 grüne 16 -1 fdp 14 plus 1 afd
elf linke 5 prozent beide unverändert
eine mehrheit glaubt dass eine ampel
koalition zur lösung der probleme im
land beitragen würde die anhänger von
union und fdp zweifelt das dankeschön
mathias seger und ausführlich können sie
das zdf-politbarometer ab 22 uhr im
heute journal sehen und schon jetzt und
jederzeit online in unserer zdf heute
app dort finden sie alle zahlen und
grafiken zum durchklicken
wenn die 20 mächtigsten länder der welt
zusammenkommen kann man sich auf
proteste einstellen auch dieses mal beim
g 20 gipfel in rom der morgen beginnt
heute trafen sich bereits die finanz und
gesundheitsministerin und minister und
auch us-präsident beiden ist schon vor
ort für eine audienz beim papst andreas
postel mehr klimaschutz unterstützung
für die armen länder der welt eine faire
verteilung der korona impfstoffe das
fordern die demonstranten schon vor
beginn des g20 gipfels in rom es gibt
eine schreiende ungerechtigkeit und wir
fordern von den g-20 dies zu beenden sie
müssen existierende impfdosen die auf
der welt nicht genutzt werden die
geortet werden sofort verteilen in die
ärmeren länder wegen der zu erwartenden
proteste sind hier in der stadt seit
tagen die sicherheitskräfte in höchste
alarmbereitschaft auch am trevi brunnen
wo das gruppenbild der staats und
regierungschefs entstehen soll nach den
ruppigen auftritten donald trump so die
hoffnung komme mit us präsident joe
biden mehr gemeinsames handeln auf die
weltbühne zurück doch nachdem
afghanistan debakel und dem u-boot
streit mit frankreich ist er sichtlich
bemüht die verstimmungen im
transatlantischen verhältnis auszuräumen
höhepunkt für die beiden heute die
begegnung mit papst franziskus erst nach
john f kennedy erst der zweite
katholische us-präsident ebenfalls
bereits eingetroffen olaf scholz der die
bundeskanzlerin ab morgen bei den
bilateralen treffen mit den mächtigen
dieser welt begleiten wird viele länder
auf der welt gucken darauf was in
deutschland geschieht sie wollen dass es
so
ist dass man sich auf deutschland
verlassen kann in der eu in der nato in
den internationalen zusammenarbeit
strukturen wie bei g7 und g20 und
deshalb ist es ein gutes kontinuität
signal dass die kanzlerin und auch hier
gemeinsam mit den anderen ländern
sprechen können und sicherstellen können
dass alle sich auch weiter auf
deutschland verlassen
ein erfolgserlebnis ist bereits
vorzuweisen die globale mindeststeuer
soll morgen auf dem g-20-gipfel
feierlich beschlossen werden anders als
joe biden wird gastgeber mario draghi
die präsidenten chinas und russlands
dabei nicht persönlich begrüßen können
sie werden sich nur aus der ferne per
video konferenz in rom zuschalten und
in rom ist für uns auch eine gellinek
das ist ja außergewöhnlich die kanzlerin
dem finanzminister scholz also mit zu
treffen unter anderem mit dem us
präsidenten eine amtsübergabe sozusagen
warum macht merkel das
tatsächlich verbringt angela merkel und
ihr voraussichtlicher nachfolger olaf
scholz verbringen die beiden das gesamte
g20 wochenende sozusagen im doppelpack
merkel nimmt scholz mit zu einem
bilateralen treffen mit dem
us-präsidenten zu einem gespräch mit dem
türkischen präsidenten erdogan und zu
einer viererrunde mit emanuel marco reus
johnson und beiden zur westlichen iran
strategie das heißt also stolz nimmt
hier deutlich nicht als finanzminister
teil sondern eben als zukünftiger
bundeskanzler und genau das ist das
signal dass angela merkel senden will an
die g20 partner nämlich dass
verlässlichkeit herrscht in der
deutschen außenpolitik dahinter liegt
versteckt vielleicht auch noch eine
andere botschaft die merkel eine gewisse
freude bereiten dürfte nämlich eine
botschaft an die autokratischen
herrschaften im g20 club seht her herr
putin in russland oder hertie jinping in
china so geht ein demokratischer so geht
ein zivilisierter machtwechsel in
deutschland danke für diese einschätzung
anne gellinek
zu den g-20 gehört ja auch die
europäische union innerhalb der eu gibt
es gerade streit so hat das
europaparlament jetzt die eu kommission
vor dem europäischen gerichtshof
verklagt der kommission wird vorgeworfen
und tätig zu sein weil sie eine neue
regelung gegen rechtsstaat verstöße in
mitgliedstaaten wie polen nicht anwender
nahe der deutsch polnischen grenze bei
görlitz hat die polizei am morgen einen
toten geflüchteten gefunden
zeugenhinweise hatten die polizeikräfte
zu einem kleintransporter geführt aus
dem gerade etwa 30 menschen ausstiegen
ein 32 jähriger iraker wurde tot
aufgefunden
die todesursache ist noch unklar nach
dem fahrer des transporters wird
gefahndet ein weiterer mutmaßlicher
schleuser wurde festgenommen
der us-konzern facebook gibt sich einen
neuen namen meter wird die dachmarke
künftig heißen es sei an der zeit die
identität des unternehmens zu
überarbeiten erklärte konzern chef
zuckerberg mit dem namen knüpfte an
seine vision eines sogenannten
metaversum sun ein virtueller raum der
die nächste generation des internets
werden soll für die gut drei milliarden
nutzer innen der einzelnen plattformen
wie facebook whatsapp oder instagram
ändert sich nichts
nicht einmal mehr zwei tage dann heißt
es nächste halt welt zumindest für
astronaut matthias maurer am sonntag um
7 uhr 21 deutscher zeit soll der
51-jährige gebürtige saarländer abheben
zur internationalen raumstation
maurer wäre der zwölfte deutsche im all
und der vierte auf der iss viele jahre
hat er darauf hingearbeitet jetzt kann
sein traum in erfüllung gehen claudia
beck
ankunft am us weltraumbahnhof cape
canaveral die kuh begibt sich von hier
aus in eine strenge quarantäne
als erster deutscher reist matthias
maurer mit einer privaten raumkapsel von
space sechs zur raumstation iss schon
lange hat er vor allem davon geträumt in
ruhe die erde von oben genießen klein
und abgeschlossen unser planet ist und
diese dünne schicht die atmosphäre die
das ganze leben auf der erde erst
ermöglicht wird tatsächlich die von
außen wirkt das hat eigentlich jeden
astronauten sehr tief berührt und ja
eigentlich zu einem botschafter zum
schutz unseres planeten werden lassen
ein halbes jahr lang wird maurer auf der
iss leben mehr als 100 experimente
durchführen 400 kilometer weiter unten
in seiner heimat im saarland sind sie
mindestens so aufgeregt wie er und
bereiten schon eine riesige party für
den abflug vor gemeinschaft betont
maurer ist ganz wichtig im kleinen wie
im großen
und als menschen haben wir festgestellt
wenn wir zusammenarbeiten dann können
wir viel viel mehr erreichen besonders
in europa ist es wichtig für uns dass
wir als europäische nation erkennen wir
können hier in der ersten liga in der
raumfahrt liga mitspielen wenn wir
zusammenarbeiten
heute gibt es noch ein wunsch essen für
maurer ist dass fisch morgen der medizin
check und dann kann die mission genannt
cosmic bis am frühen sonntag morgen
starten
und wollten sie schon immer mal einen
astronauten eine frage stellen dann
haben sie gleich die gelegenheit und
zwar dem astronauten alexander gerst um
halb acht in zdf heute live in unserer
app und auf unseren social media kanäle
und wir kommen jetzt zur fußball
bundesliga norbert herr gib sie am
morgen ein besonderes spitze da empfängt
der tabellenfünfte union berlin den
spitzenreiter aus münchen wobei die
bayern ja gerade alles andere als spitze
sind wegen des pokal debakel gegen
gladbach am mittwoch ob die münchner das
so einfach wegstecken können
wieso fragen sie sich in münchen konnte
das passieren 0 zu 5 in gladbach
ausgespielt und vorgeführt wie eine
schlechte kopie ihrer selbst
in aller erster linie aber gezeigt dass
wir ja dass wir menschen sind und keine
maschinen kimmig und das im kern des und
die haftstrafe die angedrohte zu viele
diskussionen zu viele gedanken nebenbei
am ende glaube ich nicht das ist wenn
die themen nicht gewesen wäre hätte mir
glaube ich auch nicht gewonnen am
mittwoch und jetzt zu union den
tabellenfünften zu hause ungeschlagen
seit 21 spielen für dino toppmöller
spiel 4 ohne den chef neben sich 1 1
trennten sich beide vor fast einem jahr
die bayern sind gewarnt
eva strafe für union berlin nach den
antisemitischen vorfällen bei der
konferenz league partie gegen maccabi
haifa werden beim heimspiel am
donnerstag gegen rotterdam die ränge
teilweise leer bleiben dort wird dann
ein uefa banner mit der aufschrift nein
zu rassismus zu sehen sein und zum
basketball da hat bayern münchen das
erste aufeinandertreffen mit den dauer
rivalen alba berlin in dieser saison
gewonnen im euroleague duell unterlag
der deutsche meister einer hart
umkämpften in einer hart umkämpften
partie daheim mit 69 zu 82
fünf minuten vor schluss ist noch alles
offen dann drehen die bayern in rot auf
und zeigen sich treffsicherer als die
berliner die nach langer gegenwehr jetzt
zu viele ballverluste haben nick reilly
web gehört bei den bayern zu den
spielern die am ende den unterschied
ausmachen die gäste aus münchen
entscheiden die partie mit 82 zu 69 klar
für sich das team von trainer andreas
thierry kommt zum dritten sieg in der
euroleague
dort gerade eben hat alexanders wäre es
beim atp turnier in wien das halbfinale
erreicht
am sonntag beginnt die un-klimakonferenz
und hier kommt ein ganz besonderer
redner schon mal vorab ein dinosaurier
stürmt die generalversammlung erfordert
die regierungschefinnen und chefs auf
sich gegen das aussterben zu entscheiden
und die klimakrise zu bekämpfen bei uns
was ein asteroid was ist eure ausrede
sagt der computeranimierte tyrannosaurus
der film stammt vom entwicklungsprogramm
der un dass damit vor allem subventionen
für fossile brennstoffe anfangen will
das ruhige hochdruckwetter bekommt
störungen mehr dazu gleich von ist
intelli das heute schon mal können sie
heute um 22 uhr sehen mit bettina
schausten
wir sagen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das ruhige
hochdruckwetter bekommt marken uns war
aus dem westen nähert sich regen und
kann dann im tagesverlauf durchaus ganz
im westen auch intensiver ausfallen
ansonsten herrscht zumindest im osten
noch hoher luftdruck schauen wir uns mal
die details an in der nacht also im
westen schon viele wolken mit ersten
regentropfen sonst nach norden dicht
bewölkt im osten klart es auf und die
zwei sterne funkeln im südosten bildet
sich nebel hier temperaturen bis minus 2
grad reifglätte also inklusive ansonsten
im westen milder am niederrhein bei elf
grad morgen tagesverlauf also viele
wolken von westen her die regen bringen
und es kann kurzfristig auch mal
kräftiger regnen sonst gibt es viele
wolken im osten sonnenschein mit föhn an
den alpen dann auch durchaus viel sonne
wenn sich der nebel auflöst zu dort
temperaturen an den alpen bis 18 grad am
kühlsten in der eifel bei zehn grad die
kommenden tage ja da gibt es am sonntag
schauer vor allem im westen und süden
ansonsten überwiegend trocken 14 bis 20
grad ab montag wird es deutlich
durchwachsener mit regen temperaturen
gehen nach und nach zurück damit ein
schöner abend